Mind Your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar
In a rectangle, inscribe a semicircle along one of its sides
Then, inscribe a circle that's tangent to both the semicircle and the rectangle
If the semicircle has a radius equal to a and the circle has a radius equal to b
What is the value of a divided by b? I thank Manoj and Katlego for the suggestion
Pause if you'd like to give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
First, recall that if two circles are tangent their centers and the tangent point are collinear
This is because each circles' radius is perpendicular to the tangent line
Therefore, ACB will be a straight line segment. This is true for both externally and internally tangent circles
Now, to solve the problem, connect the center of the semicircle, the tangent point and the center of the inscribed circle
Notice, this will be a radius of the small circle and we will  also create a radius of the small circle by creating the tangent line to the other side of the rectangle
The bottom left corner is a square. If we extend the diagonal of the square
to the corner of the rectangle, It will also be collinear with the line we just created.
Therefore we've created an isosceles right triangle where two legs are equal to b
and the hypotenuse is equal to b times the square root of 2
The radius of the semicircle is equal to a and therefore we have another isosceles right triangle
So its hypotenuse will be equal to a times the square root of 2
Notice, we also have a radius of the semicircle right here
We'll now focus on just these triangles and in particular, we'll focus just on the hypotenuse
The entire hypotenuse has a length equal to a times the square root of 2
It also has a length equal to the sum of these individual lengths
This will be equal to a plus b plus b times the square root of 2
We then subtract a from both sides of the equation. We then factor on both sides
We then divide both sides by b and both sides by the square root of 2 minus 1
We thus get that a divided by b is equal to the square root of 2 plus 1 all over
The square root of 2 minus 1 which is approximately equal to 5.828, and that's the answer
It's a cute little problem and I think it's fun to solve
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support